let's compare and contrast science and
scientists and innovators like yourself
and the people who worked on the
manhattan project
to this moment in today is that a fair
analogy and if not
how would you contextualize what we
learned about nuclear energy versus
the potentialities of general ai
yeah so i i think i think comparing to
the
manhattan project might be a bit unfair
since that is just a weapon
i mean like look at look at ai there's
two sides of this right on the one side
you have uh things like deep fakes
that are just obviously extremely
problematic but on the other side
we are building neural nets that beat
doctors who have been in the industry
for 50 years at detecting cancer
we're you know we're gonna end drunk
driving as we know it
we are going to end any sort of
labor-related injuries
uh we're gonna let people
just do what they want to do
uh with no you know both in their their
work environment and even you know even
in their personal environment with you
know things like assistance
things like just better content and so
all of this is to say
you know the upside's huge the upside's
huge and so the question that
you know we this is the thing that
personally matters to
you know all of the team and it was a
conversation me and my two co-founders
had really really early on
in the company
i think the the thing to know here
is you can you can
choose to use this technology for good
or for evil
in any sort of you know in any sort of
world
but if you don't build the technology at
all then you don't get a say
in how the technology is used and so if
we build our chip
and we we put this chip in every
technology technological device in the
world
that's really our only shot in saying
how the course
of the usage of this technology goes